hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hello neighbor hi
neighbor how you doing you're just gonna
keep being an [ __ ] like there so what
we need is we need to solve this puzzle
and I'm not exactly sure but my
interpretation of this is there's a
house and then there's another house
with a funky attachment this could mean
the middle of the street is the starting
point and then you take left eight steps
back 24 whatever the hell that means and
then whatever the hell that means
so if the like that's the only
interpretation that I can make from this
it's not some metaphysical thing where
the house is upside down that is
literally my house and his house right
so you take eight steps left 24 steps
back that thing and that thing which
looks like a lambda and a magnet or
something okay so that's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna try that so that must be
what it is like you know I'm I don't
think I'm mistaken about that so if see
because that one's yellow I mean that
one's not red but I guess okay whatever
let's just assume that this is correct
so the midway point between these two
houses go left 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 back 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 21 22 23 24
well that [ __ ] Oh
yeah what's that I don't have any room
in my inventory got throw a [ __ ] am
not oh god damn nose right there you ass
there was something over there
stop I'm trying to be goddamnit now
you're guarding it you sack of tits okay
so I go back here there was something
back there did I get rid of what I had
in my hands probably okay yeah what is
it is it a toilet toilet plunger
god damnit again you sack of [ __ ] - stop
let me take a look at it
Oh [ __ ] stop you goopy bastard I'll
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's a magnet it is a magnet
it's a manded I can oh I know oh I know
I know I know I know I know I know I
solved something with my brain oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] how do I drop that oh
that's not that's not the magnet I don't
know what that is oh it's a bucket for
water that he put over the door to try
to trap me I guess like an idiot okay
whatever but that doesn't matter because
I have
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] just [ __ ]
don't do it [ __ ] so good that's not
gonna work on mate god damn it he's
gonna get me isn't he
he's gonna give me oh he's gonna give me
Oh what the [ __ ] was that
okay well alright then okay but man this
is it's difficult to get around this
[ __ ] but I've got what I need an
actually I'm gonna turn it what turn
that back on just so we can have some
power in the goddamn house and maybe see
everything oh well that doesn't sound
good maybe I shouldn't have turned power
back on cuz I think that's the security
cameras checking me out huh wolf [ __ ]
hope missed me [ __ ] now if I can just
get past this thing so now that makes
more sense
in the middle of the house if you go
left 8 back for between the fences
there's a magnet I don't know why it's
orange and blue but
it is what it is okay ah [ __ ] god
damn it ah [ __ ] I'm pretty sure I did it
before by crawling out like this oh well
he's gonna get me next time I fail yeah
he not good to me he not get me he not
get ha
dodged your Jill okay you go back you do
your thing
I'm gonna do my thing which is be
smarter than you and not die and not
suck and also be cool I mean that's a
lot of things at once that I said but
it's all gonna happen trust me turn off
your power again because [ __ ] you fack
you
oh he's a coming he's a right up behind
to me oh boy
well this isn't gonna lose him [ __ ]
god damnit what a bag of dicks oh
[ __ ] hell oh don't mind me as I
slammed my crotch into your face you
ever just try to vault over someone and
just end up slamming your dick into the
nose okay take Traer ah [ __ ] what [ __ ]
[ __ ] god dammit god dammit why is
that [ __ ] impossible ah [ __ ] god
ah [ __ ] you
yes [ __ ] hell okay so yes just like
that that's how that's supposed to go
[ __ ] this Apple alright so now I got
this I got this
it's a key case you didn't know okay got
that
now with the flashlight back on he's
stuck there forever and now I go
upstairs with freer and how can I do I
cannot see ya I'm point at key whoop I
am point unlock undo it opened now okay
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] okay alright alright close
this door he's still thumping baseline
whoa
the [ __ ] is that is that supposed to be
what the hell is that who built this
house who did any of this at the [ __ ]
why is there a hole okay well the
question is do I want to drop down there
and I don't think I don't think I do but
I also think that maybe I should power
on the house okay sorry about that
didn't mean to do sorry about that okay
you know what I'm just gonna go down
because what's the worst that could
happen
ah oh okay go me through this blue now
that I got that out of the way let me
explore this room there's a closet
there's another flashlight
get this off of here Liz okay well that
opened up that opened up some doors here
oh okay that opened up this door and
that means that open - whoa benda
doesn't seem right I'm pretty sure
that's some sort of info what the [ __ ]
was that
so where did this go okay that doesn't
make a lot of sense
but I guess I think I might have seen
that hey can't close it it's too strong
I can't do it I'm too wimped okay I
really wish I could turn the power back
on well that's locked so what's the
point okay so what I need to do is I
need to get the power back on I'm pretty
sure that's a step
not just this power but I need to get
the actual power in the house back on is
he still stuck he is still stuck good
maybe he should [ __ ] stay that way
okay so powers back on in the house he's
still stuck good but I don't know how
much longer he's gonna last like that
hey buddy
yeah I'm just gonna keep exploring your
house don't mind me whew
right well turn that on
all right that's on so what is this dude
does this do anything
whoa-oh-aah so the question is can I
make it all the way over here to there
in time
whoa can I get up that goddamn couch can
I get on there
why [ __ ] god damn it I got tripped up
by this goddamn lamps get the [ __ ] out
of my way I just need to get everything
that could be out of my in my way out of
my way
then I'll be okay I'm on this side I'm
not gonna exactly make it whoo nope not
gonna make that that that's not gonna
work maybe if I go backwards on it
maybe if I dab on him [ __ ] so there's
got to be a way to get up there it's
gotta be away it's quick but it ain't
that quick oh maybe if I use the magnet
can I use the magnet to repel I can't
[ __ ] see anything but maybe I could
use the magnet to repel but either way
the power is on so I need to see this so
OOP douche okay
so can I use the magnet to push and pull
that thing whoa whoa I did it I did it I
did it I don't oh I didn't do it where
the [ __ ] am i oh I did not do that okay
well I almost did it
so maybe just the timings gotta be
better ah [ __ ] okay what happens if I
throw this at it
[ __ ] not my flashlight nope well did
it
okay got it oh come on I'm gonna get up
here you're gonna tell me that it's
gonna be [ __ ] locked the [ __ ] you
doing with my life
this [ __ ] bouche but maybe I get over
there there might be something over
there ah [ __ ] there's a banana I got a
banana
what do I do okay oh I know what I could
deal with this banana I could make him
slip and fall that doesn't tell me is
there anything over here that I could do
nah nah man man there's a lot of agility
puzzles in this more than I would have
thought anyway I got up there but I just
I can't open it yeah and there's oh
there's a top
oh I didn't even see that not that I
could have gotten up there anyway I
guess if I'd have brought something up
with me maybe let me let me just as an
experiment I'm gonna I'm gonna leave all
my stuff no [ __ ] I just wanted to drop
it somehow my [ __ ] magnet got thrown
into the abyss oh it's down there well
at least I know where it [ __ ] is
alright so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna bring oxes with me and I want to
try to get up there again so I'm gonna
bring it down it's just a matter of
timing oh yes okay easy-peasy so I don't
know if there's anything actually up
there but maybe there is whoo hey if I
if I am careful about this whoops okay
not that careful whoa okay not that not
that brash okay that's not gonna work
here okay hey no path [ __ ] it well is
there anything up there that I need oh
all I needed was one oh all I need to do
nice shoes it I got but all I needed was
one really yeah it's gonna be tough but
I gotta imagine that's why there's so
many boxes here I mean it's gotta be it
right why else would they have on the
box so all I got to do is I just got to
get one cuz I just got to get up high
enough then get one on so just wood
gentle like a baby okay so I'm up
is there anything up there no why not
says the cat no there's nothing up there
I just saw there's nothing it's all red
herring there was no purpose to any of
that a waste of my goddamn time and I
can't get in that goddamn room oh boy
okay so so now I've got another puzzle
and I don't know how to solve it oh wait
maybe I should look here oh maybe I can
maybe I can use this to grab that thing
no that's no any of this could I grab
any okay so this gate is pretty much
locked down
there might be a way around eventually
it's in here whoa oh oh hello oh well
that's good I have a key card I have a
key card but I don't know where a key
card goes have I seen a key card hole I
don't know if I've seen a key card slot
anywhere I mean now would be a good time
to explore because there's a lot of
different places around here I could get
to it still doesn't work oh there goes
yep that didn't do nothing
that did nothing that did a whole lot of
nothing oh I gotta do it twice because
that's perfectly logical
okay so somewhere hello hi okay goodbye
thank you for being an [ __ ] all right
so somewhere in this house there's a key
card and I'm gonna find it hey I see
your buttocks
don't worry I'll fix him eventually it's
not too fair to be playing with him like
that so I am gonna get him back into
normal order but I'm gonna find what I
need first and then I'm gonna do it
because I'm a fair understanding
gentleman huh nope that didn't make it
I've got the wimpiest arms in the world
hey did Wow okay nice spin but no effect
Pinsky it did break okay
that is interesting oh this one too
how does kick it bro is there so what
the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is that I
didn't see any big spinning dildo
outside of his house before all right
but I can get up there I know I know I
can get up there I've done it before no
no no if I need this key anymore but I'm
gonna do it just in case
yay war did it first try but let's see
if I can do this first try I don't need
to sprint yes okay there's something out
here there's a big splitting dildo
that's cutting I don't know what the
[ __ ] that is is that even supposed to be
there right so there's something here
what is this oh the gate clipped through
the ceiling here I don't think I'm
supposed to see this oh I don't know why
I'm here
I don't think oh where does Oh that does
that does lead somewhere the ladder a
ladder oh there's a ladder up there so I
know I can get up oh hell oh oh oh well
I don't trust myself on this one
haha [ __ ] [ __ ] ha [ __ ] oh god
oh god I hate jumping puzzles oh I hate
it okay I don't I might oh that's gonna
be a tight one you might be able do yes
get the [ __ ] out my way can I get up
there is it a matter of just grabbing
onto it please tell me it's just a
matter of touching it
huh oh water oh [ __ ] what are you open
yes okay whoa I don't know where I am
but I'm up high I'm up hi baby I'm up
high okay I'm not a PI but I'm up high
the [ __ ] is that
hang on wait let me let me just drop
this oh [ __ ] I can't see a goddamn thing
okay um is there anything that I could
what's let me just see okay I can't get
through here but there's something here
there's a vault in there oh that's weird
looking that's that's a little
disconcerting whatever the hell's in
there whoa some setup fluid maybe okay
but I gotta get this out of the way so
let me just drop this for a second I can
see it at least where it is for that out
of the way pick this back up again and
open this where does this go now where
the hell are we now ooh
oh I don't think I'm supposed to see
this either I think maybe this [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
oh no oh my god maybe I've reached a new
level of not supposed to be here Ness oh
I could jump on the tracks but that
might be a bad thing because it was hard
enough to get up here as it is let me
see if there's absolutely anything else
here and then I'll think about it
yep there's nothing else here and I
can't get through this door whatever
this bikini bottom esque looking [ __ ]
door is I have no [ __ ] idea what it
is I could jump onto the tracks that is
the thing I could do I may fall through
them it nope I'm on them I'm on I am on
them I am upon them railroad closed
maybe that's for the best but is there
ooh that's a tight jump that's a tight
jump but I can make that oh yeah baby oh
it's locked
well wait is it way is it locked is it
locked
something weirds about this door if a
magnet it it nope something very strange
is going on with this door here
is there anything on the other side of
it can I see whoa the [ __ ] is that oh my
god that is a QR code that is a [ __ ]
QR code I do not know what that QR code
does but I'm about to find out I read it
come on read that oh come on you can
read that maybe it's half of a QR code
that might be half of a QR code whoo
[ __ ] [ __ ] where to go god damn it Oh III
it might be just half of a QR code and
there's another half somewhere here so
I'm gonna take a picture of this just
because I can okay so I've got half a QR
code half half of a QR code doesn't
really help me a whole lot but I've got
it I don't know what it means but I have
it so the last thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna try to do this goddamn jumping
puzzle again
cuz if I can figure it out then I should
be okay but it it's just annoying
because number one I hate jumping
puzzles whoo it's this it's this one
pillar that's in the way here [ __ ] no
god [ __ ] damn it
you [ __ ] could you stop throwing jars
of horse semen Jesus Christ why do you
have so much of that [ __ ]
so is there is there or is there not
another half of a QR code somewhere in
this house that's what would make the
most sense to me
there must be another QR code somewhere
hidden in this house and the developers
know that there's a little bug that you
can look through things but I don't know
[ __ ] okay well that at least got me back
here haw haw haw haw haw okay where the
[ __ ] else do I go well that didn't help
me much maybe over this thing no hop
wool boy careful careful careful where
do I go that is a good question on a
[ __ ] you know e oh [ __ ] [ __ ] knife ah
[ __ ] oh where am I now where am I now
whoa I'm somewhere new okay I'll take it
oh this just loops back okay that just
looped back okay so anyway that's all
the time I got for this episode here
I've made some good progress but I've
also made some mistakes
I saw the jumping puzzle but then I
jumped in the wrong place so let me try
it one more time let me try to go up
there one more time and I know I know
I'm still using him being stuck in the
wall to my advantage but wouldn't you
guys do
boink okay back off
fire fire okay done done [ __ ] you all
right you didn't want me to do it so I'm
not gonna do it so I bet the caller QR
code maybe is up that way but I'll get
that maybe in the next video so we'll
see I have no idea but either way thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down the
comments below and what other secrets I
can explore so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
buh-bye
[Music]